[Music]
what's up eileen
not much how are you super good how
about you
i'm all right
uh-oh um what happened yeah well
actually that phone call right before
kind of hit close to home
my question to you i guess is kind of
how do i get my marriage and family life
back on track oh man
well
i guess kind of a little bit of
background i'm 26 my husband's 27. we
got married pretty on 21 22. so we're
going on five years here
um i've got three kids we've got one
that just turned four two-year-olds and
a three-month-old
i'm a trauma nurse i work full-time my
husband is a subcontractor has his own
business um
and we've kind of been really working
hard the last five years we've paid off
my schooling we've just finished
building our home
um and we have a decent marriage but
things just don't seem to slow down for
us
i feel like we're both just so exhausted
at all times and we just can't get on
track
yeah
man i'm so i'm sorry and i hear that
little i hear that little baby in the
background it's all good trust me i got
i got two myself it's all good
um you got you got three small kids or
two
i've got three
a four-year-old a two-year-old and a
three-month-old
three oh my gosh okay
so
a couple things number one
you've been married five years did y'all
date for a couple years before that
no it was like from the time we met
to getting engaged to getting married it
was like a year and a half
wow
way to go moving quick i love it
um okay so
you are in what i call the window
five to seven years is a window seven to
ten years is a window
and then that
15 to 18 years is a window
and it's a window where
you
are
running and gunning this is the one
y'all are in running and gunning you
married somebody
then there's a lot of new variables like
jobs and work in school and i don't know
three kids ages four and
under right so you throw all these
things in there and here's what happens
we stop liking who we become
yeah
and that reflects how we that that
impacts how we then
interact with other people most
importantly the person that we love and
committed our life too
and so these are seasons when marriages
start to have cracks in them and people
start to get exhausted and they start to
lean this way and that way right
and it's often people will blame their
partner in this deal
that's usually not it usually
i don't like who i've become i don't
like how i look i don't like how i feel
i don't like i used to be fun and spunky
and i just want to go to bed every night
at 4 45 p.m right
oh yeah all those things right so
tell me about eileen
you sound like an incredible woman
why are you struggling with eileen
honestly i can't even
figure that out myself i feel like
before i was really energetic
really outgoing i was a people person i
come from a bigger family i'm one of
seven the second of seven and my husband
is one of nine oh so you all just get
started yeah
we come from large families and it just
feels like we're almost like used to
this chaos
in a way but now that we've got work and
we have a farm and we've got the kids
and we both work full time it's like
even things such as date night there's
such a burden
and i've like tried to do the whole
thing you know i've listened to your
show where it's like schedule it on the
calendar
sometimes i'll do that and we're just
there and i'm like well do you want to
be intimate he's like do you want to be
intimate i'm like no i'm tech me too
and he's like let's go to sleep wait the
three month old is up the toddler's back
in our room and yeah it's like
i just feel so burnt out and i don't
even know who i am i put on like 70
pounds with the three kids i started
going to the gym but even going to the
gym it's like i
constantly have all these things i need
to get done
that my mind it just never turns off and
i feel like i'm not being a good mom i'm
not being a good wife i hate i always
loved being a nurse until maybe the last
two years i hate doing that
but i don't know what i like yeah
you know and so i don't
i don't even know i guess who i am
anymore
and my spouse is great he's always you
know if
he's always encouraging me to go out and
to kind of do things for myself and when
i'm just completely burnt out he takes
over when he's really exhausted i try to
you know cover for him but it's just
like we can never be in a good space at
the same time almost
wow thank you for articulating that
you're awesome
um
have you heard me talk about bricks
in the backpack
all right
so
this was an important
moment for me and
me getting well years ago okay
um
you can have trauma as a kid you can be
the big car wreck and we think of the
word trauma you know this you're a
trauma nurse
like man
people
i've been in trauma units with some
regularity for a season
it's stunning the things that people
find themselves wound up in right yeah
wow literally wound up in things
sometimes right so we
we know of trauma as the big thing they
got covered in two weeks later they were
dead they got hit by a car he was
cheating on her for 15 years and she
didn't know and he had another family we
know of big t trauma
and so when i think of trauma we were
all born with a backpack and some of us
were born into families that were the
only african-american family in the
neighborhood that's trump that's hard
right when you look around and see
nobody looks like you
families who are born into abuse family
who's born into
this is just the way we do things the
wrong religion the whatever the thing is
so people are launched into the world
with cinder blocks in their backpack
some of us have none some of us have
several
and over time in our life
they we we collect these bricks over
time
and then i ran into my friend um dr lynn
jennings she is a
she researches secondary traumatic
stress
and i didn't know what that was
and
the the there's a whole back story to it
it's an extraordinary thing and it gave
me so much insight into my own
physiology my own body
when you live and work and walk
alongside people who are hurting for
your job when you go into the fire
to help others
it's vicarious trauma it weighs on you
too and it might not be a cinder block
but it might be pebbles or it might be
medium-sized or tennis ball sized rocks
that go in your backpack day after day
patient after patient
moment after moment hard conversation
with family after hard conversation with
another family
and over time in short order if you're a
trauma nurse that weight in your
backpack is the exact same of somebody
who grew up in a big time traumatized
household and you're carrying that
around and then you've got so just
picture yourself with this huge backpack
full of rocks because every day you're
putting in
um
you're taking care of people right
you're intubating people you're jabbing
them with all kinds of whatever things
you're putting in their arms and bags
whatever you're doing there's a trauma
nurse right sewing people up holding
people together right
and then you walk out with this backpack
full of bricks on and you're like well i
gotta go be sexy tonight that ain't
happening
and by the way i got a three month old
that my body is still a
uh
a machine slash jungle gym
and yeah i got to get done with that
with i got to get done with work so that
this guy can then get all hands right i
mean
at some point what you have to do is you
got to deal with the trauma
whether it's secondary trauma whether
it's real trauma whether it's a
combination of both most of us have a
combination of both and
i can't tell you
how hopefully you can hear my voice
how
lighter i walk through my life now that
i got came up with like i got a system
for dealing with these secondary trauma
that i got a system for dealing with the
big bricks
and i got a system for dealing with it
when they show up time after time and
some of that's meeting with a counselor
some of that's you've heard me talk
about my daily gratitude practice and
journaling practice and exercise
practice and taking care of my body
those things practices in and of
themselves i don't think work if they
aren't tethered to somebody who has
a strong sense of
i'm okay with me
and right now you're not okay with you
but i need you to hear me say it's
because you're exhausted because you're
carrying around all these bricks
if you can set those down
holy smokes
then you walk into the bedroom and
you're like i must be tired anymore
you can go dancing with your friends
you're not so exhausted anymore your
head doesn't hurt your back doesn't hurt
there's remarkable stories there's a
great book by paul conti about trauma
that folks will drop 50 pounds
after
several months of trauma counseling
um
just letting their body process this
stuff and then they're able to move on
and their body quits holding on to
whatever that pathology is
how do i practically start i mean
doing that i guess it's a great question
all right here we go the first thing is
i want you to grab a book
um it's called trauma stewardship
anybody working in
as a trauma nurse should have a copy of
this book when i did a practicum working
with
traumatized and sexually abused kids my
practicum advisor dr gomez gave me this
book and said you cannot work with these
kids until you read this book
i made it to chapter 7 and i had to put
it down
and i called him and said i made it to
seven men i'm really struggling with
this book it was hitting home hard and
he laughed and he goes wow man i'm only
to chapter nine right it's a hard book
and it is critical okay
in that book there's several practices i
will give you a few too in fact i want
you to hang on the line um i'm gonna
give you a copy of my brand new book on
your past change your futures exactly
what this is okay okay um it's not gonna
come out until april but um i'm gonna
put you on the list to give you a copy
of it okay as part of a pre-order and
here's another thing
it comes with a free month of counseling
from better help okay do you have a
counselor in your area
i wouldn't know okay
okay oh we should i mean i just haven't
i guess taking the time to you do i
promise um all of this starts with this
i want you to say these words out loud i
am worth being well
i'm worth being well
if you're not well
your kids can't be
your husband's not gonna be
the people you care for are not gonna be
and when you're a brand new mom of three
bananas beautiful wonderful maniacal fun
kids
and you're also loving and taking care
of people every day and trying to keep a
farm up and
you're proud and you're in love with a
guy who's also keeping his business
running in full speed
you go to the bottom of that list
and somehow we picked up this awful
narrative that everybody else needs to
be taken care of before we do
and i need you to begin to say nope i've
got to come first for a season
i've gotta make sure
that my oxygen mask is on first before i
try to put it on my kids
what does that practically mean
that means that
you go to bed and you and your husband
work out some sort of schedule with the
kids
that may mean you got to get one of
those little pump machines you may
already have one and husband's got to
wake up a couple nights a week
that may mean that you're going to cut
back on your hours and you are going to
slow down on your wealth building for
the next few years
and create an environment where you can
get some your body can get some rest or
maybe you transfer out of trauma and you
move to another unit
that may mean that you're going to
journal every day
and you're going to talk about i miss my
old old eileen and who is new eileen
becoming who is she gonna be
and you
do go to the gym
and you do say
i'm gonna be a good steward of my body
i'm worth feeling good so i'm gonna put
mostly good stuff in my body unless girl
scout cookies are out and let's be
honest then we're all just going to go
we're going to crush them right
i've got a trauma guide
trauma 101 guide you can go to john
delaney.com and go through that
but i want you to begin to
write down on a piece of paper
what does eileen need to be well
what does well mean for me
is it sleep is it connection i'm telling
you right now just listen to your story
you need need to connect with a
counselor
and
i'm going to give you a free month of
counseling with betterhelp that's that's
online counseling if you have a
counselor in your community i'd love for
you to start there as well okay okay
and this is not
um you sacrificing your kids time your
husband's time this is you being well
and your husband deserves to be well too
uh what are you both working so hard for
i i don't know i i honestly think
it's kind of that idea we have a picture
of what life should look like i came
from a family that was
quite well off he on the other hand did
not and i think he's trying to i noticed
that like my husband he tends to give
the kids a lot of gifts he constantly
buys them things and we're financially
well off and for me
i guess as a child i grew up having a
lot of things so i just don't care for
them as much as he does he puts a lot of
value on those things so you're running
you're running two something and he's
running away from something
yeah and here's what i want you to do
both of you stop running
stop running
and so you've listened to the show
enough to know that i'm gonna tell you
you all need to get out you've got three
kids
clear the deck
great your parents are awesome awesome
that was fun it was fun growing up and
being rich and we had a good time and
his parents didn't have a lot they loved
him clearly he's great at loving you and
those kids awesome
what do we want our one
wild crazy
looney tune reckless filled love life to
look like
just us too and our three little kids
and probably the other nine we're going
to add later on
right i don't know about that what do we
want this is ours it's nobody else's you
all get to paint the picture and this
eileen should be exciting
and fun and oh my gosh let's walk
together towards a thing not run from
something
yeah let's hold hands and walk to a cool
thing and we're going to take 50 years
to get there and then we're going to be
we're going die right we're gonna be
dead it's gonna be exciting hopefully
i'll make it longer than that
but and and
that's where this thing ends up let's
reverse engineer that what do we need to
do right now you know we need to do
right now i'm gonna work less we're
gonna make less money i'm gonna be home
more i'm going to sleep more i'm going
to be intentional or i'm going to keep
going trauma nurse and husband
man we're going to hire somebody for
this farm we're going to slow things
down a little bit we have to we got to
because we're worth it i'm worth it
you're worth it let's back this thing
down a little bit
and that may not be the solution but
it's an option and when both of you are
running and gunning and flying and going
and going
it just feels like hey this train can't
stop and what i want you to do is it can
it absolutely can
and it all starts with you're worth
being well
and now let's reverse what does well
mean what does well mean what does it
look like what are the behaviors we need
to do what are the thoughts we have to
do all of it let's go to john.com check
out the trauma 101 guide we're going to
get you hooked up with this book this
book will walk you through it start to
finish i have a feeling this this book
was written for you eileen it's written
for you
man and let me say i'm so grateful for
you you are awesome
great mom great wife
great trauma nurse i know you're
exhausted and you're cooked i know
you're fried and your body has had it
it's time for healing